هذا ليس محجرًا عاديًا، إنه المكان الذي
دفن فيه الأحياء موتاهم في
بون ساهالا في غزة التي جوفتها
الحفارات الإسرائيلية، كانت هذه كلها قبورًا، كانت هذه
مقبرة لكن الجيش يقول
إنهم أجبروا على المجيء إلى هنا
لأنهم اكتشفوا نفقًا لحماس
يمتد إلى اليمين  تحت تلك المقبرة،
لكن الجيش الإسرائيلي فشل في إثبات
هذا الادعاء المذهل خلال جولة مدتها 3 ساعات
في المنطقة، حيث قاموا بدعوتنا إلى هنا بعد أسبوع
من اكتشافنا لأول مرة
للتدمير الجزئي لهذه المقبرة باستخدام
صور الأقمار الصناعية كجزء من
تحقيق أجرته شبكة CNN والذي عثر على 16 مقبرة
في غزة.  تضررت أو دمرها
الجيش الإسرائيلي، هذه المنطقة بأكملها هنا عبارة عن
مجمع عسكري من المسجد
هناك أسفل المقبرة على طول
الطريق شمالًا وجنوبًا، في
البداية نحاول تطويق هذه المنطقة
بإطلاق النار من هذه المنطقة مرارًا
وتكرارًا  لا يمكنك أن تفهم السبب،
وبهذه الطريقة تحدد أنه كان هناك
نفق هنا لأنه تم
إطلاق النار عليك، نعم يا
سيدي، تبدأ رحلتنا للتحقيق في
مزاعم الجيش الإسرائيلي في
أنقاض ما يقولون إنه
مبنى سكني حتى لو كان قائمًا فقط
عند مدخل هذا النفق، يمكنك أن تشعر
بالرطوبة تمامًا كما تنبثق هنا،
وهذه هي الطريقة التي ندخل بها إلى
ما يقولون إنه نظام أنفاق واسع النطاق
في بوني سوا، حيث
ننزل إلى متاهة مظلمة لا نهاية لها على ما يبدو،
هناك مساحات ضيقة مثل
هذه بالتأكيد  أجزاء من هذا النفق ولكن
بعد ذلك تصل إلى هنا ويكون لديك مجال كامل
تقريبًا في كل أنحاء النفق، يمكنك أن ترى أن
هناك كهرباء وهناك
اتصالات يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي
إن نظام الأنفاق هذا يؤدي في الواقع
إلى مركز قيادة حماس الذي
يقولون إنه كان يستخدم من قبل حماس  المقاتلون لتنسيق
هجماتهم يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إن
مركز القيادة عبارة عن غرف متعددة
مجهزة بالسباكة والكهرباء.
خرائط مثل هذه بمجرد تبطين الجدران،
يمكنك رؤية مطبخ هنا مجهز
بحوض مياه جارية مع الأنابيب التي
تمر عبر جدار النفق لديك
لوحة مروحة يعني يمكنك أن تتخيل
هذا في منزل ولكن بدلاً من ذلك فهو
عميق تحت الأرض أين نحن
الآن أعني ما فوقنا لذلك نحن في
مقر
قائد حماس أه فوقنا مقبرة أه
التي أظهرتها  أنت من الخارج، إذا
نظرت إلى صور الأقمار الصناعية
لهذه المقبرة، فهناك مساحة واسعة قام
الجيش بتطهيرها، لماذا يعد ذلك
ضروريًا للكشف عن هذه
الأنفاق، كان علينا
الوصول إلى الأنفاق التي كان علينا الوصول إليها
الأنفاق التي كان علينا أن نمنعها
من أن تحاصرنا العدو ولكن
لا توجد طريقة لنا للتحقق مما إذا كنا
بالفعل تحت المقبرة.
يعيدنا الجنرال غولدفوس إلى خارج النفق
ولكن ليس إلى المقبرة بدلاً من ذلك
نغادر بنفس الطريقة التي دخلنا بها  قبل
العودة إلى الحفرة الهائلة حيث كانت
المقبرة ذات يوم،
يرجى الانتظار لثانية
نعم، نحن نسأل الجنرال إذا كان بإمكاننا
بالفعل رؤية النفق المؤدي إلى النفق ولكن
الإجابة هي لا، لذا هناك جميع أنواع
الآلات التي لا أريدها  أريدك أه
فقط أن تلتقط صورًا
لعلامة الأمان، ماذا لو لم نقم بتصويرها،
ثم قد تسقط في
الأمر برمته، أو قد ينهار أو يتعين عليك
المشي إلى الحافة، ولم يتم
تأمين الحافة  يمكن أن تنهار هناك الآلات،
لذا فهذا ليس شيئًا
سأخاطر به، آسف،
قدم الجيش الإسرائيلي لاحقًا
لقطات طائرة بدون طيار تظهر عمود النفق الذي
دخلناه وقامت
CNN بتحديد الموقع الجغرافي للقطات باستخدام
صورة القمر الصناعي هذه، يوضح هذا المخطط التفصيلي
المكان  كانت المقبرة قائمة ذات يوم وهذان
هما مدخلا النفق
خارج المقبرة بوضوح أما بالنسبة للنفق الذي
يقولون إنهم وجدوه هنا حيث كانت
المقبرة ذات يوم لم
يقدم الجيش أي
دليل على الإطلاق